[Music]
in honor of women's history month we've
been talking with female leaders in
sports politics
business and entertainment this morning
we're speaking with u.s senator tammy
duff she is an
army veteran a democratic lawmaker from
illinois
and a mother of two in 2018 senator
duckworth shared a letter she wrote to
her younger self for our series
note to self but that wonderful life
won't end
so abruptly it will feel like a death
and will put the rest of your plans for
your family
for your career on life support the
helicopter pilot lost both legs when her
national guard unit was shot down over
baghdad
you'll almost die but you'll make it
just barely your survival won't have
anything to do with your own abilities
you'll make it out alive completely
because of the grit sacrifice and
outright heroism of others
you haven't done anything to be worthy
of their sacrifices
but these heroes will give you a second
chance at life
anyway
your second life begins when you wake up
a few days later
in agony non-stop unrelenting
seemingly endless agony but you will
re-emerge
this week she is releasing her first
book every day is a gift
senator duckworth good morning as we
just heard you almost died when your
helicopter was shot down you lost both
of your legs
but you have said that if you could do
it all over again you still would
why oh heck yeah
well two things the first of course are
the my my buddies the men and women i
got to serve with for all those years
my helicopter crew there's just nothing
like it they're some of the most
honorable
funny uh brilliant people i've ever met
and that includes people i've met since
i've been in the senate so
just getting to serve in my unit again
would be
priceless and plus i also love to fly
helicopters
so that would be great too senator you
grew up in
thailand uh you are biracial you face
discrimination for being half white
you were on the brink of of you were
almost below the poverty line living in
hawaii as a teenager picking up coins
for money
you talk about this experience as almost
a vaccine
preparing you for what was to come later
why is that
and how did that how did those
experiences shape you
you know i didn't really think of it
until i wrote the book
and then towards the end of the process
of writing the book i looked back and i
realized wow
all the things i described in the book
you know growing up as a kid following
my dad around
southeast asia being afraid that my dad
wouldn't come back
um when he went back to the states for a
year feeling afraid of being abandoned
all the way through to as you said you
know real extreme poverty in hawaii i
talk about selling flowers out of a
bucket by the side of the road and
you know um and picking up coins off of
the street and
uh looking back after i finished the
book i realized wow
overcoming those were real hardships for
me it was just my life
but overcoming those real hardships you
know probably set me up for being able
to face the biggest challenge i was
going to have which was recovery after
my shoot down
i know your book was so candid senator
you you say that
the hardest thing for you wasn't so much
the shoot down wasn't so much
the painful recovery it's what happens
to you in your dreams what you see in
your dreams
that is probably the most painful for
you and how it affects you and your
daughters
could you talk about that well sure i i
wanted gail to be
very upfront about everything i've been
working a lot on on
veterans healthcare and veterans mental
health and asking veterans to please get
help
um and in the book i talk about you know
if i
watch too much uh media on the iraqi
afghanistan you know wars in iraq and
afghanistan um
i actually as i described him i hope you
know i think i did a good job of it i go
to bed
in my bed in illinois and i wake up in
iraq
and i live this entire full day and i
can i remember all of the landing zones
all the lz's i remember all missions i
mean
even the mundane things that you would
have to do as part of the day
you know cleaning the windshield to your
helicopter all of i go through that
entire
you know 18-hour day what you said about
your legs
this was so fascinating to me because
you had the option of getting cosmetic
legs
which you thought that's what i want but
in the end that's not what why you took
that's not what you chose why
because they remind me of floss it's
just like you know when i would wake up
from one of these
dreams in the next day i i would have
left lived a whole life
and then i have to go through the laws i
remember oh wait that's not me now
this is me now and go through that loss
of my legs again and those cosmetic legs
are beautiful and i
there are lots of folks who who amputees
who love them and wear them but for me
they symbolize lost not where i am today
so i prefer my metal legs my titanium
ones because
those are strings senator duckworth i
want to touch on what's going on in the
country right now with asian americans
you've made the point in the book and in
recent interviews
that asian americans are in a unique
role in american culture on the one hand
they're not seen as minority enough to
deserve protection
or assistance but on the other hand
they're also forever
the other do you think that that dynamic
may be breaking
as we recognize the struggle of asian
americans right in this moment
boy i sure do hope so you know i and
that other
experience is very very real i will tell
you that i've actually been asked by
fellow americans
while i was wearing my uniform with the
american flag on my shoulder where i was
really from
like wait a minute you know in the book
i talk about this my family has been
here since before the revolution i have
ancestors who fought in the french and
indian wars and here's people asking
me where are you really from and i'm
literally wearing
the uniform of my nation with her flag
on my shoulder you had a moment with the
biden administration you said you were
offended by something they said to you
about kamala harris
well i you know i i was pushing for more
representation at the highest levels of
the biden administration
i love kamala she's my girlfriend you
know we we were freshmen in the senate
together
um i've spoken with her they actually
the
the folks in administration actually
brought up her name and said well
you have kamala you know you don't
really need any other asians in the
cabinet and i thought
wow that's really offensive you wouldn't
say we have a white male president there
should be any more white male
uh members of the cabinet why would you
say that to someone from the asian
community
so but we worked it out and then they
are i'm so pleased that they're putting
somebody in the white house west wing a
very senior
uh member of the uh you know the staff
who will be aapi will help us
navigate these issues and bring up
issues of real concern to asian
americans like the under reporting of
violence against asians
senator tammy duckworth thank you so
much the book every day as a gift goes
on sale
tomorrow we'll be right back it is good
yeah